did you know that the world is ruled by
one company
Taiwan semiconductor Manufacturing
Company may not be a household name but
its chips are everywhere
in iPhones air conditioning units smart
doorbells computers cars F-35 fighter
jets and even NASA's perseverance Rover
that landed on Mars the reason
automakers haven't been making enough
cars is because of a shortage of these
sophisticated chips that power functions
like braking semiconductor chips are the
new oil in terms of our dependence on
them and one company pretty much has a
monopoly
nestled on the northwest coast of Taiwan
tsmc produces 92 percent of the most
advanced chips in the world it's one of
only two companies that mass produces
chips below 10 nanometers the other
being Samsung nanometer refers to the
length of a transistor tiny switches 10
000 times thinner than a human hair that
control electric currents one nanometer
is equal to one billionth of a meter the
smaller the transistor the more that can
be crammed together the more transistors
you have the better the chip and the
more powerful your computer will be when
house Speaker Nancy Pelosi visited
Taiwan in August 2022 she made it a
point to meet with tsmc chairman Marco
Liu a sign of just how important the
company is Beijing spent weeks telling
Pelosi not to go to Taiwan an island
that Chinese president Xi Jinping
believes is a breakaway Province and is
threatened to invade in light of
Pelosi's visit Beijing sanctioned Taiwan
by suspending in Imports of citrus
fruits and fish of course Beijing did
not ban Taiwanese semiconductors because
it relies on them like everyone else
semiconductors have become a key part of
the tech rivalry between the U.S and
China their concerns that an invasion of
Taiwan by China could choke off the
supply of these cutting-edge chips to
the rest of the world and give Beijing
control of this essential technology
so how did Taiwan semiconductor become
so dominant
the fundamental technology was actually
invented in America and gave Silicon
Valley its name as most chips are
created with silicon in the 90s the U.S
manufactured a third of the world's
chips today none of the advanced chips
is made in the USA companies like Intel
used to build and design chips in-house
but beginning in the 1980s American
firms started struggling against
competition from Japanese companies so
they Outsource some parts of their
business that were draining their
profits including the expensive
factories that produce semiconductor
chips Morris Chang noticed this trend
and took advantage of it he was born in
China and in 1949 he moved to the states
where he eventually earned a PhD in
electrical engineering from Stanford he
spent 25 years Rising through the ranks
of Texas Instruments but for the
Taiwanese government offered him a
chance to develop its semiconductor
industry Chang realized there was a
great opportunity to create a new
company focused solely on making chips
that could supply all needs in 1987 tsmc
was born
Chang initially priced the chips at a
loss to capture a larger market share in
the hopes that costs would eventually be
reduced enough to generate a profit his
strategy paid off big time the world's
largest companies all rely on tsmc Apple
Intel Qualcomm AMD Nvidia Huawei and
Tesla manufacturing semiconductor chips
that are the size of a fingernail is
crazy difficult each chip is packed with
as many as 50 billion transistors the
process begins by cutting silicon Wafers
these thin slices of semiconductors that
kind of look like shiny mirrors into
individual chips employees must wear
protective gear when handling them if
even a speck of dust Falls onto the
wafer the entire batch risks being
ruined the chips are made by etching
tiny patterns across the wafer layer
upon layer to create the layers the
wafer is coated with a light sensitive
chemical it's kind of like lay clearing
a cake except in this case the cake has
75 layers and takes three months to make
the layers are connected by copper wires
that carry electrical power the entire
process is daunting and tsmc has the
Undisputed Edge but things are getting
complicated as it finds itself caught in
the middle of a tug of war between two
superpowers in August President Biden
signed the ships act into law which bans
companies that receive American
subsidies for manufacturing
sophisticated ships for China any that
are below 28 nanometers Washington is
offering 52 billion in subsidies to
encourage manufacturers like tsmc to
build semiconductor plants in the U.S
one is scheduled to open in Arizona in
2024 which tsmc previewed on its
LinkedIn page but it will still
represent only a small sliver of global
chip production at the same time Chinese
chip Innovation is growing by Leaps and
Bounds in 2020 Chinese firms were still
struggling to get below 40 nanometers
today leading Chinese chip company smic
is said to have successfully made a
seven nanometer chip researchers at the
firm Tech insights say the chip was made
for crypto mining China has made it a
strategic priority to boost its domestic
semiconductor industry showering Chinese
chip firms with incentives including
exempting them from paying corporate
income tax for up to 10 years if they
make the most sophisticated chips
still for now Taiwan semiconductor is
the most important ship manufacturer in
the world it's producing ships that are
two nanometers smaller than China and
vast assert manufacturing Ultra Advanced
two nanometer chips by 2025. that means
your iPhone would last four days without
needing a charge China needs tsmc just
as much as the United States does as
geopolitical tensions rise Taiwan
semiconductor's importance on the world
stage may be the Island's greatest
protection against any possible invasion
if you'd like to learn how to make
videos like these skillshare is an
incredible way to pick up new skills and
you can try it out for free I initially
joined skillshare more than a year ago
to learn how to make better thumbnails
for my videos and then I happen to
stumble across another one of polymado's
classes on how to make animated videos
and I've pretty much been addicted ever
since there's something for everyone no
matter your interests you can learn how
to edit videos or improve your editing
skills if you already have some
experience you can get tips on how to
speak confidently on camera or develop
good productivity habits the skillshare
is great for both your hobbies and your
business you can join me on skillshare
for a free trial by clicking on my
custom link in the description the first
1000 people to use the link will get a
one month free trial of skillshare
thanks for watching for newsthink I'm
Cindy Palm